No funciona así. Es un sentimiento.
Así que ¿de dónde viene ese sentimiento?
Si nos remontamos 50 000 años atrás
a la era Paleolítica,
a los primeros días del Homo sapiens,
encontramos que el mundo
estaba lleno de peligro,
había muchas fuerzas que operaban muy duramente para matarnos.
Nada personal.
Ya fuese el tiempo,
la ausencia de recursos,
quizá un tigre dientes de sable,
todas estas cosas contribuían
a reducir nuestra expectativa de vida.
Por eso hemos evolucionado como animales sociales,
viviendo y trabajando juntos
en lo que yo llamo un "círculo de seguridad" dentro de la tribu,
donde nos sentimos como si perteneciésemos.
Y al sentirnos seguros entre los nuestros,
la reacción natural fue la confianza y la cooperación.
Hay beneficios inherentes en esto.
Significa que puedo dormir por la noche
y confiar en que alguien desde dentro de mi tribu velará por el peligro.
Si no confiamos en el otro, si no confío en ti,
significa que no velarás ante el peligro.
Mal sistema de supervivencia.
Hoy en día es exactamente lo mismo.
El mundo está lleno de peligros,
cosas que están tratando de frustrar nuestras vidas
o reducir nuestro éxito,
reducir nuestra oportunidad de éxito.
Podrían ser los altibajos de la economía,
la incertidumbre del mercado de valores.
Podría ser una nueva tecnología que hace que
tu modelo de negocio se vuelva obsoleto de la noche a la mañana.
O podría ser tu competencia
que a veces trata de matarte.
A veces trata de sacarte de carrera
o, por lo menos,
trabaja arduamente para frustrar tu crecimiento
y robarte el negocio.
No tenemos ningún control sobre estas fuerzas.
Son una constante,
y no van a desaparecer.
La única variable son las condiciones
dentro de la organización,
y ahí es donde importa el liderazgo,
porque es el líder quien marca las pautas.
Cuando un líder elige
poner la seguridad y la vida
de las personas dentro de la organización en primer lugar,
sacrificar sus comodidades y sacrificar
los resultados tangibles, que hacen a las personas permanecer
y sentirse seguras y sentir que pertenecen,
ocurren cosas extraordinarias.
Yo estaba volando en un viaje,
y fui testigo de un incidente
en el que un pasajero intentó abordar
antes que dijesen su número,
y vi a la agente de la puerta
tratar a este hombre como si hubiese violado la ley,
como a un criminal.
Le gritaron por intentar subir
demasiado pronto.
Así que le dije:
"¿Por qué nos tratan como ganado?
¿Por qué no nos tratan como a seres humanos?"
Y me dijo, exactamente:
"Señor, si yo no sigo las reglas,
podría tener problemas o perder mi trabajo".
Me estaba diciendo
que no se sentía segura.
Me estaba diciendo que
no confía en sus líderes.
Nos gusta volar en Southwest Airlines
no porque contraten necesariamente a mejores personas,
sino porque ellos no temen a sus líderes.
Si las condiciones son erróneas,
nos vemos obligados a gastar nuestro tiempo y energía
en protegernos de los demás,
y eso inherentemente debilita a la organización.
Cuando nos sentimos a salvo dentro de la organización,
naturalmente combinamos nuestros talentos
y nuestras fortalezas y trabajamos sin descanso
para hacer frente a los peligros externos
y aprovechar las oportunidades.
La analogía más cercana que puedo dar
sobre ser un gran líder, es la de ser padre.
Si piensan qué significa ser un buen padre de familia,
¿Qué desean? ¿Qué hace a un buen padre?
Queremos dar a nuestros niños las oportunidades,
la educación, la disciplina cuando sea necesario,
todo para que puedan crecer y lograr más
de lo que logramos nosotros mismos.
Los grandes líderes quieren exactamente lo mismo.
Quieren brindar a su gente las oportunidades,
la educación, y la disciplina cuando sea necesario,
construir la confianza en sí mismos, darles la oportunidad de intentar y fallar,
todo para que puedan lograr más
de lo que podríamos imaginar para nosotros mismos.
Charlie Kim, director general de una empresa llamada Next Jump
en la Ciudad de Nueva York, una empresa de tecnología,
hace referencia a que
al atravesar momentos difíciles en la familia,
¿alguna vez consideraron despedir a uno de sus hijos?
Nunca haríamos eso.
Entonces, ¿por qué consideramos el despido
dentro de nuestra organización?
Charlie implementó una política
de empleo de por vida.
Si uno consigue un empleo en Next Jump,
no puede ser despedido por problemas de rendimiento.
De hecho, si tiene problemas,
le van a entrenar y darán apoyo,
al igual que lo haríamos con uno de nuestros hijos
que regresa a casa con una nota mala de la escuela.
Es todo lo contrario.
Por esta razón mucha gente
tiene un odio visceral, un enojo tal,
a algunos de estos ejecutivos bancarios
con esos salarios desproporcionados y las estructuras de bonificaciones.
No son los números.
Es que ellos han violado la propia definición de liderazgo.
Han violado este contrato social profundamente arraigado.
Sabemos que permitieron el sacrificio
de su gente para proteger sus propios intereses,
o, peor aún, sacrificaron a su gente
para proteger sus propios intereses.
Esto es lo que lo nos ofende, no los números.
¿Alguien se ofendería si le diésemos
un bono de USD 150 millones a Gandhi?
¿Qué tal un bono de USD 250 millones a la Madre Teresa?
¿Tenemos un problema con eso? Ninguno en absoluto.
Ninguno en absoluto.
Los grandes líderes nunca sacrificarían
a las personas para salvar los números.
Antes sacrificarían los números
para salvar a las personas.
Bob Chapman, que dirige
una gran fábrica en el medio oeste de EE.UU.
llamada Barry-Wehmiller,
en 2008 fue golpeado muy duramente por la recesión,
y perdió el 30 % de sus pedidos, de un plumazo.
En una gran empresa manufacturera
eso es algo importante,
porque no podía mantener su mano de obra.
Tenían que ahorrar USD 10 millones,
por lo que, al igual que muchas empresas hoy en día,
se reunió el consejo y analizó la opción de los despidos.
Y Bob se negó.
Verán, Bob no cree en el recuentos de cabezas.
Bob cree en el recuento de corazones,
y es mucho más difícil simplemente reducir
el recuento de corazones.
Y así se les ocurrió un programa de licencias.
Todos los empleados, desde la secretaría al CEO,
estaban obligados a tomar 4 semanas de vacaciones no remuneradas.
Podían tomarlas en cualquier momento que quisieran,
y no tenían que tomarlas de forma consecutiva.
Pero fue la manera en que Bob anunció el programa
lo que le importaba tanto.
Él dijo, es mejor que todos debamos sufrir un poco
a que cualquiera de nosotros tenga que sufrir mucho,
y la moral subió.
Ahorraron USD 20 millones,
y, lo más importante como cabría esperar,
cuando la gente se siente segura y protegida por el liderazgo en la organización,
la reacción natural es la de confiar y cooperar.
Y, espontáneamente, nadie lo esperaba,
la gente empezó a intercambiar entre sí.
Los que se podían permitir más
intercambiarían con los que podían permitirse menos.
Algunas personas se tomarían 5 semanas
para que otro solo tuviera que tomar 3.
El liderazgo es una elección. No es un rango.
Conozco a mucha gente en el más alto
nivel en una organización
que definitivamente no son líderes.
Son las autoridades, y hacemos lo que dicen
porque tienen autoridad sobre nosotros,
pero nosotros no los seguiríamos.
Y conozco muchas personas
que se encuentran en la parte inferior de las organizaciones
que no tienen ninguna autoridad,
pero son líderes absolutos,
y esto se debe a que han elegido cuidar
de la persona a la izquierda de ellos,
y ellos han elegido cuidar
de la persona a la derecha de ellos.
Eso es un líder.
Escuché una historia
de unos marines
que se encontraban en el teatro,
y como es costumbre de la Marina,
el oficial comió último,
y dejó que sus hombres comieran primero
y, cuando terminaron,
no había comida para él.
Y cuando regresaron al campo,
sus hombres le trajeron algunos de sus alimentos
para que coma,
porque eso es lo que pasa.
Nosotros los llamamos líderes porque van primero.
Los llamamos líderes porque toman el riesgo
antes que nadie.
Los llamamos líderes porque van a elegir
sacrificarse para que su gente
puede estar segura y protegida
y, por lo tanto, para que su gente pueda ganar
y, al hacerlo, la respuesta natural
es que nuestra gente se sacrificará por nosotros.
Ellos nos darán su sangre, sudor y lágrimas
para ver que triunfa la visión de su líder,
y cuando les preguntamos: "¿Por qué hiciste eso?
¿Por qué darías tu sangre, sudor y lágrimas
por esa persona?" todos dicen lo mismo:
"Porque ellos lo hubieran hecho por mí".
Y, ¿no es esa la organización
en la que a todos nos gustaría trabajar?
Muchas gracias.
Gracias. (Aplausos)